Ramona Shelburne is back here on the
show great stuff Ramona thanks how you
doing I'm doing great
so I guess answer the question how how
did Kauai pull jord Paul George away
from OKC at what point did he finally
connect with him and get an answer that
that gained some traction in the process
well you know it almost feels like the
free agency was kind of like an episode
of The Bachelor king where you're going
on here going on multiple dates with
multiple people at the same time so what
was interesting about wisely agency
which we haven't seen in a couple years
usually lately it's raisins have just
been kind of deciding on July 1st not
that there's not really much recruitment
but in Hawaii case he was he was meeting
with the Clippers on Monday night he was
meeting with the Lakers on Tuesday
afternoon about 12:30 out of the four
seasons in Westlake and it appears
you've met with Paul George on the same
day he's meeting with the Lakers and
Paul lives in Los Angeles about the same
kind of area and I was like villages and
Calabasas up men in that general area
and then on Wednesday he fly if
Wednesday morning at 5 o'clock in the
morning and we also had that on the
footage he flew to Toronto and hung out
there for a couple of days and so I
think what was interesting about the
whole but the whole story is like we all
I mean I don't feel like I knew Kauai I
don't feel like any of us really know
him we know him as a basketball player
and how incredible he was during the
playoffs the Raptors but personally I
guess I just didn't know you had that in
it to be recruiting Paul George away
from the Oklahoma City Thunder it's one
thing to one thing to like call somebody
is seasonal play with you because so
that was that was the first hit that he
was after a second star with the
Clippers is when he called he actually
called Kevin Durant before free agency
began it's asked if he'd be interested
in going to the Clippers with me and
that didn't go very far just to ramp was
already pretty far down the road
thinking you were going to go to
Brooklyn with Kyrie Irving in DeAndre
Jordan but the idea that why is
recruiter
that's like who knew that I know he was
into yeah that's what we're saying on
the on the show here yesterday is a you
know who knew board man was chairman of
the board man you know and you know and
and in terms of Durant and also even
Jimmy Butler I mean their fellow
unrestricted free agents that makes
sense
Paul George is deep under contract I
mean deep under contract and also as I
mentioned here yesterday the model that
Toronto was supposedly following which
is get the guy who you wouldn't normally
think would come to your town have him
stay there for a year let him see what
what it's like to be there let him see
what our organization and fan base in
cities like and Paul George did see that
with Oklahoma City and stayed and Kauai
did that in Toronto it was the ultimate
success he wins it all there and a vault
able to call and get the team up in Los
Angeles where George didn't come when he
had a chance for LeBron to team up with
it's amazing I on nobody saw this thing
coming my question for you with all this
Ramona's that is a set up is where the
Lakers really even in this if he's
thinking of tot teaming up with people I
mean what was the Lakers real shot to
get Kawhi Leonard what it all comes down
to it yes I think I think what's hard to
tell is you know people tell you things
afterwards right during it you know
there's a lot of there wasn't a lot of
reporting coming from the team right
that was part of the whole deal and
recruiting quiet that everyone was
supposed to keep their mouth shut and
then if you talk too much that was gonna
hurt your chances and like all three of
the teams were trying to abide by that
but afterwards he started to hear things
more from Kawhi scamp and even around
the league right so that's just the idea
that the Thunder even made this trade
because let's go back to the idea that
Paul George had asked for a trade from
Oklahoma City with two years left on his
deal and Oklahoma City had you oblige
that trade request in the time that was
allotted neither of these people had to
do this right and and there's no reason
there was no real incentive doing it on
Paul George's timeline on Kawhi Leonard
timeline except if you want to avoid
creating the super team with the Lakers
that I that as a motivation for everyone
involved for the Clippers and giving up
all those draft picks Oklahoma City in a
obliging Paul George's trade request
indeed doing it on that timeframe that
that's a real motivation because if if
you really believe that Kawhi Leonard is
gonna go to the Lakers which I think the
team's involved in I think they all day
believing then you have to do it because
if you don't now you have LeBron Anthony
Davis in Kawhi Leonard with the Lakers
for years to come and you have to deal
with that for years to come so I think
that was a whether it was real or not
everybody involved believed it hmm and
you know if you go if you look back on
it you know I've subsequently heard it
was very real then he was very close to
go to the Lakers and you the Clippers
don't make this trade but but I again
that that's what you say afterwards okay
that's what people say afterwards I
think it's the only way you can evaluate
what actually happened is the actions
that people took and the actions that
goai Leonard took work recruiting Kevin
Durant and Paul George to try to come
play with him with the Clippers and his
desire to play in Los Angeles this
desire to play with the Clippers has
been had been pretty well reported and
documented throughout the year so those
are actions he actually called Kevin
Durant he actually recruited Paul George
he actually got Paul George to ask for a
trade like this is how you have to
interpret this and I I believe that
everyone involved on he was going to go
to the Lakers if he did well Ramona
Shelburne here on the Rich Eisen show so
the thing I'm trying to square here is
that let's just say Sam Presti actually
said no right
pay Paul too bad you know I mean we're
all invested here and if I trade you
that means I might have to raise this
whole thing down to the ground as it
appears he is doing right now and I'll
get to that in a second with you so what
would Kawhi after calling everybody to
try and team up with him would he have
just said you throwing all the chess
pieces up and there I you know what I
tried you know
Dennis and I we tried but you know I'm
just gonna go join LeBron and Anthony
Davis and their super team he wouldn't
have just gone to the Clippers or just
gone back to the Raptors I mean based on
all that you're hearing Padgett I just
it just strikes me as odd you don't try
all that just what you know the answer
to that right there the only like what I
heard was you've got to go to the Lakers
and I've heard that subsequently for
that people right before and after the
trade but the only people who can really
tell you in their heart of hearts look
who I would have done kokkonen is squat
and maybe his almost made maybe maybe
his friend Jeremy Castleberry because
I'm sure they were talking about all
this but this is I think the question
was Sam Presti in Oklahoma City and sort
of what they had their their gambit here
okay I they didn't have to trade him in
his time frame but that was taking a
risk of creating a super team in LA with
the Lakers but it was also something
where they felt like they had is heat
leverage with the Clippers and with the
Raptors because making this trade is in
some ways was making a trade for Kawhi
Leonard right it wasn't just trade for
Paul George it was a trade for Paul
George to get Kawhi Leonard and let's
make her what let's say Kawhi is like
you know what I want to be with the
Clippers we can do this trade for Paul
two months from now and maybe we won't
have to give up as much maybe this new
team I'm joining will be stronger so
Paul they could have waited if Kawhi
would have taken that leap much like
LeBron the year before right LeBron
fences it was the same kind of gambit
that the Lakers had to play with LeBron
you know the year before and he ended up
coming on his own and he stayed all by
himself without that second star for a
whole year but what what happened then
is that the trade demands fan fold and
an Arnold Palmer's the public or not
work if they'd to make the public but
either way you have an unhappy superstar
there and there with two years left on
his deal you can't exactly put the cap
back on that bottle right I mean I we've
seen what happens when a superstar
either asked for a trade or make it
public or gets reported I mean I I don't
think that would have sat me long
I think you know enough of us had an
idea of what was going on behind the
scenes and and whether people would
confirm it or not is another thing but
at some point somebody would have got
enough to report it I mean I I had heard
it before a couple of days but it was
nobody would confirm or go that deep
into it and I think it's I don't think
it what is that I think it would've got
reported and I think it it then puts the
Thunder C's in peril and actually kind
of kills their leverage like once the
trade demand is public in some ways that
it hurts your leverage and I think Sam
Presti looked at it and said this is not
what we wanted to do they exist this
group probably had another year left in
it but if it's if it's gonna go this way
you better get ahead of it and get as
much as you can and I think they thought
this was the most they could get but
with that leverage of the free agency
approaching so then the last two
involves Sam Presti in Oklahoma City and
and the moves here number one woge your
colleague and saying that let me get the
wording right Russell Westbrook is
welcoming to idea of Sam Presti
engineering a trade they were bringing
in to his illustrious 11 year thunder
career so under the concept of what you
just mentioned with Paul George it's out
there now I mean is there any turning
back what what happens with Westbrook
here Ramona yeah turning back like we've
been talking about about Chris Paul for
a couple months now right when when he's
gonna get traded and whether he would
have welcomed a train and where he might
want to play if he were to be traded I
mean this you know nothing I I think
with with Westbrook than the wording
there is delicate and I've been involved
in writing stories like that where you
you really choose your words carefully
because what of course the avoidance is
you know he hasn't yeah I can't say this
position won't just ignore the story
okay I don't I don't know but the
question is is he welcoming to a trade
is that the same as asking for a trade I
don't think that you know we're in the
same ballpark right maybe but in some
ways it actually matters it matters a
lot whether you asking for a trade or
you're welcoming to a trade and and most
people sometimes you just kind of throw
out what smoke trade
Vlad you forget all those words that are
so carefully chosen by whoever wrote the
story but I think it I think that
matters
because I don't know that they trade him
I know that it would probably is always
better to once once something's out in
the open and and uncomfortable it's it's
usually better to move on as quickly as
possible but Westbrook is a foundational
piece in Oklahoma you don't get a chance
to you know you know you know how you
don't get a player like that very often
and if you have to trade that player or
if you feel like you have to trade that
player you better do it right and it's a
tricky contract to trade I mean he's not
coming he's not exactly a peak value if
not coming off a banner season he looks
like a guy that lettuces and was
starting to wane his flaws the player
looks worse with age you know there's an
argument to be made that they should
just bring him back and run it back for
the first you know 20 games of this year
and let him rebuild his value yeah and
then see where they end up but you know
so as much as you know they would be
nice to have a resolution I'm sure just
for the comfort factor of everyone
involved I don't think you rush that
unless you feel really good about it
right when the last one for you
certainly since you have been on the
inside of how as you mentioned Kawhi
pulled Paul George away from Oklahoma
City you know when all the dust settles
and and and I you know Clay Bennett the
the chairman of the team and Sam Presti
look at each other what the hell
happened
do they demand the league look into some
sort of tampering of something I'm not
accusing the Clippers of anything they
might just be following up on what Kauai
wants but Paul George was just seemingly
sitting there happy before the phone
rang and the question is is what of a
thunder do do they have any recourse on
any of this don't think so I mean I
think it's a larger conversation to have
for the league to have and the owners
are in Las Vegas right now talking about
stuff like this you know right now at
the Board of Governors meeting but this
is a new trend where it's almost like
your contract doesn't matter okay
however many years you have left on your
deal like as soon as you get you know if
you're tired of your team if you want to
go someplace else players just ask for
training the league has historically
find the players for doing
publicly or at least admitting to it
publicly but like Anthony Davis agent
got fined $50,000 but I thought stopping
anybody okay and I think the notion of
players recruiting each other has gotten
louder but I think that's kind of always
been done so I you know the league has a
problem in the sense that this is very
disabled izing so all franchises when
superstar players ask for trainees sort
of kill your leverage you're doing it on
they're doing it on their terms not
yours but the reason why it's so
destabilizing is because the NBA has has
artificially created an environment
where it is that's where it makes it so
much harder to get a superstar of that
calendar right like it makes it so much
it's that much more damaging because we
don't have true free agency we have we
have a system that's engineered to get
players to stay right where they are and
I think when you have you either go all
one way or all another and I I think we
might have to go the other direction we
might have to have a true free market so
that if you lose a star you can you can
get one again soon soon afterwards it's
not as hard to get one because now it's
becoming so commonplace for players to
just bleep Ramona Ramona thanks again
let's let's get you in studio at some
point okay
I know I've always been a chat soon
that's Ramona she'll burn of ESPN for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app